hello everyone I'm Sumit Gulwani and
I'm going to show you demo of some of
our program synthesis technologies
inside notebooks these technologies
generate code from user intent expressed
in some form the task at hand today is
to analyze 9-1-1 calls data set this
data set contains details of various
9-1-1 calls in CSV format so the first
step in analyzing this file would be to
ingest it into a tabular form or a
panda's data frame that I can then
visualize and do for the processing over
this is commonly done using a popular
Python library called pandas and
specifically the read CSV API so let me
use that oops something went wrong here
hmm the error here isn't very
constructed what was it trying to do I
simply had a CSV file that I'm trying to
read using the read CSV API okay let's
look at this file
AHA so this is not a pure CSV file it
has some metadata at the top and then a
list of column names and then the real
CSV data begins here which I need to
appropriately account by passing proper
arguments to the read CSV API turns out
that this read CSV API has 50 parameters
so either I can go to a stack overflow
or I can look at pandas documentation to
figure out which of these parameters to
use and what appropriate arguments to
pass to this specific invocation of the
read CSV API but instead of doing that
let's use program synthesis to over
rescue here so one of the domains for
which we have invested in program
synthesis capabilities is that of file
ingestion taking semi structured
documents and generate
parsing code to lift this in to Abel's
this capability has been exposed as a
pythonic API called read code
accelerator dot to read and when I pass
the 9-1-1 dot csv file to this api it
analyzes the pattern of the data inside
this file and uses it to generate code
that can live this file into a panda's
data frame so note that this is not any
arbitrary code but this is code that
leverages the pandas read CSV API that I
was struggling with earlier so note that
the API has automatically figured out
that there are 11 rows that I need to
skip it has figured out the names of the
various columns it has figured out what
the delimiter is what the porting
semantics that I need to incorporate and
so forth this read capability is
extremely powerful in two dimensions
first it can not only handle CSV files
but it can also generate the parsing
code for reading fixed-width files log
files custom text files JSON files web
pages and even PDF documents the second
interesting aspect about this API is
that when the underlying file format is
too ambiguous for the underlying AI to
automatically generate parsing code for
then instead of letting the user fall of
the cliff we allow the user to interact
with this API by giving examples of
various fields that they want to extract
from this document so the user can
specify one to two examples of various
fields and then in many of these cases
this API is still able to generate we
write parsing code and this is called
programming by examples some of these
capabilities have recently been shipped
inside power bi as data connectors to
extract tables from web pages and PDF
documents now back to this demo I can
leverage this code that got
automatically generated to populate the
pandas data frame now the next step in
the process is to in
this data frame so that I can figure out
what transformations do I need to do
this is often done using the static
preview that pandas has but instead we
have built our own interactive great
experience that allows some basic
capabilities like searching and
filtering but even more interestingly it
provides a great user experience for
some of our other program synthesis
technologies so let me use this
interactive grid to look at the data I
notice that there's a date column and
there's a time column it reflects when
each 911 call happened suppose I want to
figure out when our 911 calls most
common as in Monday mornings or Tuesday
afternoons to do this analysis I will
need to create a new feature of these
two existing columns in particular I
would like to map the date 12/11/2015 to
the corresponding weekday which I know
from my calendar is a Friday and I would
like to bucket eyes this time 11 : 11 :
11 into let's say a four hour bucket
indicating late morning now just imagine
how much code you will need to write to
translate this date string and this time
string into this new bucket ID string
and it is at this point of time that I
wish this was Excel and I can use the
flash fill feature that I built for them
few years ago flash fill is a popular
Excel feature that does string
transformations by examples for instance
converting first name space last name
into last name comma first name but
unfortunately flash will won't work in
this scenario because this scenario
requires reasoning about dates and
numbers which flash will does not has
how flash will is a very popular
technology there are around million
invocations of flash fill every week and
the user experience is so inviting that
it doesn't prevent people from trying
out things on which threshold was never
meant to work and invariably people talk
about cases which don't work recently on
mber 2018 oh I'm sorry I mean October
2018 there was a tweet by someone named
Aaron which received more than 10,000
shares and where he for some right
reasons made fun of the flash fill
feature so the tweet said look AI is
going to take over the word but this is
what Excel Auto populates for me today
we're in Darien give an example to
convert Dec into December and then flash
fill converts Oct into October and JN
into Jenna and so forth in fact some
people even came to the rescue of the
feature by claiming that this is how
months should have been named in the
first place or the best part about this
customer feedback is that we get
insights into what new domains to
develop this programming by example of
program synthesis capabilities for and
this is exactly what we have done so now
we have augmented flash fill with
reasoning about dates and numbers so
that it can do data number
transformations and this new flash will
plus plus capability is now incorporated
inside this notebooks variant if I give
one example of what I want the
underlying intelligence generalizes that
example into a program and runs that
program on the rest of the rows to
automate the task for me however even
more than flash fill this time we
actually show you code Python code code
that is quite readable in fact this is
another feedback that we heard from some
data scientists and developers trying to
use flash fill that they do not like the
lack of transparency with flash fill is
too much magic underneath instead they
would like to have full transparency
into what the system is doing underneath
and based upon that feedback we are now
generating readable code for users this
code also has a lot of educational value
so now for instance I know how to take a
spring and cast it as a date/time object
I never knew that percentage a was the
magic sequence of characters that I have
to use to convert a date/time object
into the corresponding weekday the user
can even edit this code for instant
instance
for our buckets they can create
eight-hour buckets and so on so now I
can use this code and incorporate it
inside my workflow to compute this new
drive column in my data frame and now
the last step left in the process is to
visualize the frequency counts of these
different time buckets to figure out
when our 9-1-1 calls most common turns
out that if we want to plot a histogram
of the frequency counts in the order of
these time buckets you again have to do
some complicated data wrangling and in
this case the intent can be best
described using natural language and
this is a capability that we are
currently working on program synthesis
for visualizations from natural language
but for now I have this code written by
hand and when I execute it I can see
when our 9-1-1 calls most common so in
fact that corresponds to Wednesday's 8
a.m. to 12 p.m. this concludes my demo
of program synthesis technologies inside
notebooks program synthesis has started
to lay the foundation for the next
generation of programming experiences
which will be characterized by Popular's
of disruption first hundred x mode
programmers because today 99% of people
who use computers do not know
programming and we have the potential to
enable these people to create small
scripts to automate repetitive tasks in
their lives secondly we have the
potential to improve the productivity of
existing data scientists and developers
by n 200 X in many task domains because
most of the code that is simple our
writing is just plumbing code and
there's very little algorithmic
creativity involved now we believe that
notebooks shall be that tipping agent
for this transition into the next
programming generational experiences
notebooks are a match made in heaven for
program synthesis for two reasons
program synthesis is good about
automatically generating small fragments
of code and this is what exactly matches
the granularity of cells inside mode
books furthermore program synthesis can
generate
readable code in a variety of target
languages using different kinds of
libraries and this can address the
challenge that notebook users will have
around polyglot programming or around
discoverability issues related to
continuous development of new libraries
and SDKs secondly the success of program
synthesis techniques relies heavily on
interactivity with the user to resolve
the ambiguity in the users intent
specification and note books provide the
ideal form factor for such an
interactivity I hope you enjoyed this
peek into the future of programming for
more details please visit my pro streams
home page or send me email thank you